というわけで良い起きてしまいました誤字者バッハ
あああああこれこれこれ
次いでペアの焼きそばゴック激辛ということで
もうねみてくださいハンデ差本当にもう無理です今度はちょっとだけでやっぱりそう
ですよね
投げるほど風が強いので小さなお子様にかなりが苦手な方の寄宿はねるぐぬさえ
さあ
どうします空か
空がですよねさっそく食べていきましょう
花
いややですけどもうやっぱりねえやん5択からするとくるしかないんですよ
おまけ外川せていただきました今回はこちらペアン国劇から10個全部食べようと思い
ます
できる2ミサもなしょうがないおれが食わなくても必ず誰か空でしょ
じゃあさっそく作っていきましょう
基本的な3体目は一緒ですモカ役は入れてありますからソースの色がもういやばいいん
ですよね
とりまお湯たします
[音楽]
はい
街ますッごく激辛のちょっと情報なんですけども
とりあえずにゃんぬ史上最強の激辛商品らしいですまで月キャラ弁のとか激辛ペアに
エンドとかあったんですけどもそれよりもはるかに辛い
嘘だ無理だお値段は205円の税別
b 待ったことじゃないんだけど辛さはわかりやすく例えますと激辛ペヤング焼きそば
エンドって黒いやつあったんですかあのもがき苦しん月
[拍手]
取った
あれの3倍の辛さらしいです待って食べが出てきた問題だ空前から汗が止まらんので
さっきからまあ辛いの苦手な人間なんで僕を送って皆さん食べるかどうか判断して
頂けると助かります僕が一番低いハードルだと思うんで本当に彼のようなので本当に
本当にカレーの甘口じゃないと食べませんから普通だと脚各タイプ
そんな
レベルの人間が動くてからペン悟空とどうなるかっていうのをぜひ皆さんに見て
いただきたいところでございますはいここまで口にうまそうなんだよね
これの色が果たして何の花ってどいつも気になる早速入れてみます
ああ
いやーや羽根は上記で上記で汗かく
サウダー
しちゃってきたぞこちらが史上最強にカレー提案ゲストが
号空隙からです日本でこんなの作るかなぁ
なくいますけど待ってましたよこういうのユーチューバー喜んでみんな君でしょうね前
は行かせていただきますよろしく思って見て食べる前ですよねそればいいんですけど
食べる前から血と汗かいてん主よここらへんとか恐怖を感じている
それ
あの辛いの弱い人間のたい道を図っておきましょう
これ日号機なりますえっ
tan
あ
day
待って
あっううぅううねバーイ
うブーブーあだかいや
超えてないんだがー
誰がってなぜか飲み物なきゃいけない
バッハ
[音楽]
一口でこのいけないは付きません
ただ
飲むヨーグルト一口でプリヤバイマって本当にまっ
まってまって本当にん
いったーーーだーっ
うわぁ
re いっっ
だがないこんな汗かくことありますそれをで本当にうまいですけどね
やばいぞこれ
これこんなに食べもなくて汗ダメだなことないっすよ普通
うそ
びっくりしちゃうはこれダメだこれもう本能的に体が止まっちゃうんですよ
今までは何か辛いけど勢いで食べなきゃってもで食べるんですけどもう動かないです手
が込んで通す北これ本当山へどうしよう
街で食べてないこれ姿みろ俺がゆうしろ
技 hd
[音楽]
行くぞ
いただきますとと抹茶だねと松永いきますいきますできますよ
本当に行きましょうでありません
ana
[音楽]
ええええええ
ううん
うーん
[音楽]
ええええええ
ぐっさーああ子って
もう神辺
ni
car
teame
me
ana あああっ
いい
ん
[音楽]
あああああ
久々にねぇ
見解を感じだ
でも耳が痛くなるタイプ
ん
いやこりゃすげーなー
[音楽]
アンビリバボー